[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
friends Partners speaker Pelosi members
of Congress who've traveled here to
represent the United States and fellow
leaders
it's an honor it's an honor to once
again participate in this critical
Summit
I'd like to thank our host president
CeCe for bringing us together at this
pivotal moment thank you Mr President
let me start by acknowledging
that this day is a day of commemoration
at home in the United States
it's Veterans Day
America's veterans and their families
survivors and caregivers are there a
spine and soul of the United States
and on this special day
on every day I honor all those of
sacrifice to our nation like my son
I want to thank I want to thank one
proud American Veteran a lifelong public
servant and dear friend and literally
one of the most decorated men to fight
special Envoy for climate John Kerry
John
John your commitment your passion your
diplomatic expertise has been absolutely
critical absolutely critical delivering
incredible progress on climate issues
over the past two years and I thank you
Val thank you for being my friend
here in Egypt the Great Pyramids the
Asian artifacts stand as Testament to a
millennia of human ingenuity
we see our mission to avert climate
catastrophe and seize a new clean energy
economy not only as an imperative for
our president and future but Through The
Eyes Of History
according to the world the World
Meteorological organization the past
eight years have been the warmest on
record
the United States and the United States
we're seeing historic drought and
wildfires in the west devastating
hurricanes and storms in the East here
in Africa here in Africa home to many
nations considered most vulnerable to
climate change food insecurity hunger
follows four years of intense drought in
the Horn of Africa meanwhile the knights
River in West Africa swollen swollen
because of more intense rainfall
is wreaking havoc on fishing and farming
communities
in Nigeria flooding has recently killed
600 people
1.3 million more are displaced
seasonal livestock migration routes have
been used for hundreds of years are
being altered
increasing the risk of conflict between
herders and local farming communities
the climate crisis is about human
security
Economic Security
environmental security
NASA security and the Very life of the
planet
so today I'd like to share with you how
the United States
is meeting the climate crisis with
urgency and with determination to ensure
a cleaner safer and healthier plan for
all of us
from my first days in office
my Administration has led with a bold
agenda to address the climate crisis and
increase energy security at home and
around the world
we immediately rejoin the Paris
agreement
we convened major climate Summits and
re-established
[Music]
I apologize you ever pulled out of the
agreement
we established major economic and major
economies Forum to Spur countries around
the world to raise raise their climate
ambitions
last year cop 26 in Glasgow the United
States helped deliver critical
commitments that will get two-thirds of
the world's GDP on track to limit
warming to 1.5 degrees Celsius
over the past two years the United
States has delivered unprecedented
progress at home
through a generational investment and
upgrading our nation's infrastructure
we're making up our power grid better
able to transmit clean energy expanding
public traffic Transit and rail
building Nationwide network of electric
vehicle charging stations over 50 000.
and this summer the United States
Congress passed and I signed the law my
proposal for the biggest most important
climate bill in the history of our
country
the inflation reduction Act
it includes less than I asked for but a
significant amount
368 billion dollars
to support
clean electric clean electric
electricity everything from onshore
offshore wind to distributed solar zero
emissions vehicles and sustainable
Aviation fuels more efficient
electrified buildings cleaner industrial
processes and Manufacturing
climate smart Agriculture and Forestry
and more
look our department of energy estimates
that the new law will reduce emissions
in the United States by about 1 billion
tons in 2030 while unleashing a new era
of Clean Energy power and economic
growth
our investments in technology from
Electric batteries to hydrogen are going
to spark a cycle of innovation that will
reduce the cost and improve the
performance of clean energy technology
that will be available to Nations
worldwide not just the United States
we're going to help
[Applause]
to help make the transition to a low
carbon future more affordable for
everyone
accelerate the carbonation beyond our
borders in fact
the International Energy agency recently
concluded that our significant climate
investment will quote help Turbo Charge
the emergency the excuse me turbocharged
the emerging Global clean energy clean
energy economy I was reading their quote
sorry
it's going to shift the Paradigm for the
United States the entire world
you know I we also ratified the Kigali
amendment to Rally the world in phasing
down the production and consumption of
hfcs greenhouse gases that are thousands
of times more damage than carbon dioxide
and just yesterday the United States
became the first government to require
that our fed our major federal suppliers
disclose their emissions and climate
risk and set targets for themselves that
are aligned with the Paris agreement
[Applause]
as the world's largest customer with
more than 650 billion dollars in
spending last year the United States
government is putting our money where
our mouth is to strengthen
accountability for climate risk and
resilience
these critical steps are already locking
in vital investments in our
infrastructure delivering lower costs
for clean energy spurring good paying
union jobs for American workers and
advancing environmental justice in our
communities
folks
we're proving a good climate policy is
good economic policy is a strong
Foundation
for durable resilient inclusive economic
growth is driving progress in the
private sector it's driving progress
around the world and some total of the
actions my Administration is taking puts
the United States on track to achieve
our Paris agreement goal of reducing
emissions 50 to 52 percent below 25
Levels by 2005 Levels by 2030.
[Applause]
let me just take a moment to emphasize
how meaningful it is that I can say that
I introduced the first piece of climate
legislation in the United States Senate
way back in 1986
36 years ago
my commitment to this issue has been
unwavering today finally thanks to the
actions we've taken I can stand here as
president United States of America and
say with confidence the United States of
America will meet our emissions targets
by 2030.
foreign
forward to do our part to avert the
climate hell that the U.N Secretary
General so passionately warned about
earlier this week
we're not ignoring harbingers that are
already here
it's true so many disasters climate
crisis is sitting hardest those
countries and communities that have the
fewest resources to respond and to
recover
and that's why last year I committed to
work with our Congress to quadruple U.S
support
climate finance and provide 11 billion
dollars annually by 2024 including three
billion dollars for adoption
that's why the Fund emergency plan for a
adaptation and
resilience prepare we call it to help
more than a half a billion people in
developing countries respond to climate
change
were already requested more than 2
billion for the prepare this year
I'm going to fight to see that this and
our other climate objectives are fully
funded today
as a down payment we're announcing more
than 150 million dollars in initiatives
that specifically support prepares
adaptation efforts
throughout Africa including adaptation
in Africa effort that Egypt and the
United States launched together in June
this includes support for expanding
early Warning Systems to help cover
Africa broadening access to climate
Finance providing disaster risk
protection strengthening food security
mobilizing the private sector and
supporting new training center in Egypt
to accelerate adaptation across the
efforts all across the continent
mine is
my Administration has also made the
United States the first ever contributor
to the adaptation fund last year and
this year we're doubling our pledge to
bring in our total commitment to 100
million dollars we're also making sure
that every dollar we deliver goes as far
as possible unlike on unlocking larger
pools of finance and the trillions in
private investment we know that will be
needed
folks we're also supporting the global
Shield a G7 initiative to better protect
vulnerable countries
everywhere from climate-related losses
and quickly respond to climate-related
damages
and the G7 LED partnership for Global
infrastructure and investment is working
to meet the critical infrastructure
needs in low and middle-income countries
with specific focus on climate
the project we're facilitating is built
on transparency partnership the
protections for workers and the
environment one of the many projects
already underway is a partnership
between American firms and the
government of Angola to invest two
billion dollars building new solar
projects in Angola
and everywhere and every like everywhere
in the world climate adaptation in
Africa is working toward energy
Transmissions as just means creating
good jobs spurring inclusive economic
growth and leaving no one behind as we
Implement a sustainable development
goals
folks now I know this has been a
difficult few years
the interconnected challenges we face
can feel all consuming
the upheaval we're seeing around the
world especially Russia's brutal attack
against Ukraine is exacerbating food
shortages and energy spikes and costs
increasing volatility in those energy
markets driving up Global inflation
against this backdrop it's more urgent
than ever that we double down on our
climate commitments Russia's War only
enhances the urgency of the need to
transition the world off as dependence
on fossil fuels
true energy security means every nation
means that every nation is benefiting
from clean Diversified Energy Future no
action
no action can be taken without a nation
understanding that it can use energy as
a weapon
whole the global economy hostage you
must stop
and so this Gathering must be the moment
to recommit our future and our shared
capacity to write a better story for the
world
let's build on our Global Climate
progress raising both our Ambitions and
the speed of our efforts the science is
devastatingly clear we have to make
vital progress by the end of this decade
that's why the United States is rallying
the world around climate game changers I
launched one such Game Changer last year
the European commission president
vonderlein the global methane pledge
we started it with the EU and eight
other countries in Glasgow and grew to
more than 100 countries now more than
130 countries have signed on to covering
more than half of the global methane
emissions methane is 80 times more
potent than carbon and it accounts for
nearly half half of the net warming
we're experiencing now so cutting
methane by at least 30 percent by 2030
can be our best chance to keep Within
Reach of 1.5 degrees Celsius Target
foreign
emissions reduction act plan which lays
out how the United States is meeting the
pledge
we're investing more than 20 billion
dollars in domestic methane mitigation
to do things like cap orphan Wells leaky
methane improving industrial equipment
and the oil and gas sectors reduce
emissions
it also lays out strong regulatory
actions including including a new
proposal from our Environmental
Protection Agency to strengthen
standards on methane across sectors
especially from Super emitters to make
so just to make sure it's not released
in the communities impacting on public
health
all told these steps
all told these steps to reduce U.S
U.S methane emissions
from coverage sources by 87 percent
below the levels of 2005 by 2030. folks
another game changer is conserving our
natural environment
whether it's the Congo basin's forest
and Peak plants here in Africa or the
Amazon basin in South America or Forest
Wetlands grasslands in the United States
preserving nature is one of the most
impactful climate Solutions we have
some that indigenous people who have
communities have known and been the
stewards of these efforts for a long
time in Generations they've known it
here at cop27 we are co-chairing forest
and climate partnership to deliver real
rapid strides to Halt deforestation
the best part is we don't have to
develop any new technologies we just
have to make clear forests are more
valuable when they're preserved than
when they're destroyed it's not facing
and those of our able should be chipping
in to help those countries in fact
preserve those great forests
we're bringing together Partners across
the public and private sector and
philanthropic sectors to put health
healthy ecosystem at the heart of
healthy economies
this is uh it's going to take all of us
it's going to take all of us we need to
harness our capacity to tackle emissions
and economic sectors like international
shipping
if the shipping sector were to
stand-alone economy for a standalone
economy it would rank as the 10th
largest emitter in the world
so together with Norway the United
States has launched the green shipping
challenge
during this cop we've seen dozens of
commitments from governments as well as
ports and private companies to
facilitate green shipping corridors and
align the sector with the 1.5 degree
goal
if we can accelerate actions on these
game changers we can't reach our goal we
can keep it within reach as well
but to permanently bend the emissions
curve every nation has needs to step up
at this Gathering we must renew and
raise our climate ambitions
the United States is acting everyone has
to act it's a duty and responsibility of
Global Leadership countries that are in
a position to help should be supporting
developing countries so they can make
decisive climate decisions
facilitating their energy transitions
building a path to prosperity and
compatible with our climate imperative
if countries can Finance coal in
developing countries there's no reason
why we can't finance Clean Energy in
development companies
I'm pleased to announce today alongside
the European Union in Germany a 500
million dollar package to finance and
facilitate Egypt's transition to clean
energy
this package will enable Egypt to deploy
10 gigawatts of renewable energy by 2030
while bringing offline five gigawatts of
inefficient gas powered facilities
reducing emissions in Egypt and power
sector by 10 percent
we also will also work with Egypt to
capture nearly 14 billion cubic meters
of natural gas which is currently flares
vents or leaks from its oil and gas
operations
and because of this cooperation Egypt is
elevating its climate ambition and
submitting enhanced National
determination contributions
if we're going to win this fight every
major emitter Nation needs to align with
a 1.5 degrees we can no longer plead
ignorance
to the consequences of our actions or
continue to repeat our mistakes
everyone has to keep accelerating
efforts throughout this decisive decade
my friends I came to the presidency
determined to be a Trent to make the
Transformer transformational changes
that are needed
that America needs to make
and we have to do for the rest of the
world to overcome Decades of opposition
and obstacles of progress in this issue
alone to re-establish the United States
as a trustworthy committed Global leader
on climate
as I stand here before you we've taken
enormous strides to achieve that
[Music]
but I don't stand here alone
this progress is being driven by young
people all across America
like young people around the world they
feel the urgency of climate and feel it
deeply they're committed to these issues
they know the stakes and that's their
world we're creating this is not to
stand by and allow us to fail in there
in this responsibility we can't
that's why as I look out of all the
things that I've we've accomplished
there's so much more to do I'm
optimistic for all the work that remains
to be done we have to put down
significant markers of progress
the United States has taken enduring
steps to meet our goals we're delivering
on our promise of leadership and more
and more the world is standing with us
so determined diplomacy is necessary
we're finding consensus building
understanding and launching new
approaches
and the inspiring passion of young
people
Civil Society climate activists
indigenous communities is literally
galvanizing the world
yes the challenge we Face are great but
our capacity is greater than the
challenge we must never doubt that
so let's Reach Out
take the future in our hands and make
the world we wish to see
that we know we need
a planet preserved for generations to
come an economy powered by Clean
Diversified secure energy sources
opportunities unlocked through
Innovation and cooperation to deliver
Equitable more prosperous more stable
and more just world for our children
that's why we're here
that is what we're working toward and we
can do it together I am confident thank
you thank you thank you may God bless
you all
[Applause]